Welcome back everyone!
Hello everybody!
I got my new hair on!
Hello.
Kept us waiting, huh?
Kept you waiting, huh?
You know, I don't think I've said that a single time.
Like, in time of playing Metal Gear 4.
I don't think.
Birthday!
MGS5 birthday song.
My first MGS game was MGS Touch for the iPhone!
Oh my gosh, that reminds me, I used to have an iPod Touch.
Actually, it was my dad's.
But, I basically stole it from him.
And I downloaded the Silent Hill game on it.
There was like a Silent Hill mobile game.
That, it was like a maze.
And you walked around the maze.
And sometimes you'd find nurses.
And I think there was Pyramid Head too.
It was not, it was, the setting was Silent Hill.
There was nothing, no substance.
It was just, it was just a thing.
Happy birthday, congratulations!
Happy birthday with salutations!
Happy birthday, may your sky stay blue!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday!
Substance, Metal Gear Substance.
Now, welcome back everybody to Act 4 out of 5.
Of Metal Gear Solid 4.
This, this act is...
Chef's kiss, so good.
Best act in the game.
For sure.
Can we talk about your voice pack?
How many times did you have to record?
Wait, wait, wait.
I didn't want to interrupt your special stream yesterday.
It was my birthday!
Happy birthday, congratulations!
Happy birthday with salutations!
Happy birthday, may your sky stay blue!
Happy birthday to you, Skeletor!
Happy birthday!
I saw your tweet being like, does she know?
Actually, it was a total coincidence, but I'm glad that it, that it, that it...
Worked out.
Yeah, the voice pack.
Okay, I guess we can chit-chat a little bit before we start, huh?
Because yesterday I didn't get really to chit-chat, because yesterday was Valentine's Day.
And I did a bit of a special stream.
If you haven't watched it, it was quite short.
So, easily digestible.
Oh gosh, the voice pack.
It didn't take me that many tries, I think.
Was it...
It was just, you know...
It was...
What do you mean X?
What do you mean?
It was not short, it was average.
No, I think average stream length is like three hours.
It destroyed you?
Why?
Why, why, why?
Always a pleasure to see you, Minto!
Thank you, Chiboron!
Thank you so much.
Either she's a stone-cold professional or she actually loves this.
Okay, but I was... I did have to...
So, actually I did get someone to write it for me.
Because I'm not very good at writing scenarios, right?
So, I had someone write it, but then I changed some stuff.
I usually have someone write something for me.
And then I will adjust to how my comfort or my...
You know, I don't want it to seem totally unnatural.
So...
Something that I would actually say, unless it's like a true Isekai otherworldly type of scenario.
Something, something.
Yay!
Thanks to Keizo!
Chat GPT?
No, if you watch...
Oh, somebody did not watch...
Oh, LMStray did not watch the stream yesterday.
No, I pay people.
I hire.
I hire real humans to write.
I didn't think the voice pack would get you guys like that.
Before stream, I said I was gonna get coffee.
And I didn't.
Because I had no decaf.
Instead, I only... I got tea instead.
So...
But yeah, I'm glad you guys liked the voice pack.
Even though it was embarrassing.
The ending of it was me being like...
Was my reaction to finishing it.
That was not in the script.
That was a genuine...
Me being like...
Gosh, I have to say this.
That was not part of it.
That was me being like...
Oh, God!
You have a haiku?
Ghost with metal gear brain rot.
That's me.
Makes everyone laugh with beauty she emits.
You're laughing at my face?
Becoming legend everyone will remember.
Oh, wait.
It's a poetry.
Snap, snap, snap.
Would you accept my second shirt button?
I sure hope that you guys don't stop snapping off your buttons.
In front of me.
When I do a meet and greet and everybody is wearing a pull-up shirt.
No, wait.
A polo shirt.
And everybody starts taking off their buttons.
Just like...
Oh, my gosh.
You go to like a VTuber convention.
And everybody is walking around with just one button.
Like popped off.
And like that part of the shirt open.
It's like becomes a new fashion trend.
Will there be yelling about Naomi in this stream?
I don't think Naomi happens in this chapter.
Oh, no.
No.
I just lied.
I just big lied.
Yes, I will be yelling about Naomi.
Oh, yeah.
Sorry, I completely forgot.
Yes.
Yes, there will be big yelling about Naomi.
I'm so sorry.
Oh, gosh.
This is the peak of her bullshittery.
Right here.
In the stream.
Time for Naomi crash.
I don't think I'll be able to watch it.
Oh, God.
I'm already getting old.
Okay.
No, I said I wouldn't cry.
Okay, I'm okay.
I'm cool.
I'm calm.
I'm a cucumber.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay.
Focus.
I'm focused.
Today's a great act.
So much cinema today.
Oh, God.
Hold on.
Let me wipe my tears.
But the voice pack, it had art with it.
Wait, not saying you should do it.
Wait.
You're not saying you should do it for this one.
But if you continue doing that for future ones, have you considered including the art file with the voice pack file?
I can.
Probably.
Let me ask the artist.
What's my DM?
Who's DMing me?
Okay.
Thank you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Happy 10 months, Mito.
Happy 10 months.
Laugh and grow fat.
Yeah.
Welcome back.
Rendog, welcome back.
MGS4 Act 4 and Bocchi the Rock Season 2 announced.
Today is a good day.
Yeah.
I did see that, that Bocchi the Rock Season 2 was announced.
Surprised it wasn't announced any sooner.
Also, it feels...
Is there like an event happening this weekend in Japan?
It just feels like a random day.
Like, is it like Anime Japan this weekend?
Or, like, any event?
Or...
Just...
They were like, yeah, we're gonna announce that.
I don't know.
It's just so funny that it's like a random...
WAN Fest was last week.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Anime Japan is next month.
Then what the heck?
Oh, hi, Mahler.
Oh...
Wouldn't you know more?
Well, how would I know?
What are you saying?
I'm such a big weeaboo that I should know every event that happens.
Every anime single...
Every single anime event that happens in Japan.
Every...
Every day!
I'm gonna build my Rex kit.
I want to see it.
Post pictures on Twitter if you have a Twitter.
Hmm...
Um...
I feel like I was gonna say something.
I don't remember what.
Oh, well.
Yay!
Spawn of thee!
Welcome back!
Oh my gosh!
Your profile picture reminded me.
You have Clannad.
But, did you guys see that Air?
The Air visual novel?
And stuff is being released on Steam.
And then also a bunch of soundtracks, too.
And, like, Natsukage.
Oh my gosh, I love.
I love Natsukage album.
Oh, it's so good!
Oh!
So, if you are a fan of, like, key visual novels...
Like, Kanon and...
Uh...
Clannad...
And...
Uh...
Angel Beats and...
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Will you scream about the Snotacon in this chapter?
I will scream about lots of things, probably.
I think that's guaranteed.
With a minion of Metal Gear.
I think so.
It was one of my first key anime.
My first key anime was...
Kanon.
I think.
Maybe.
But, I've seen...
You know what?
Actually, I own...
I have Little Busters.
I've played a little bit of Little Busters.
But, I have not seen the anime.
The anime for Little Busters took so long to come out.
And then, by the time it came out, I was, like, too busy to watch it.
And I...
There was another one.
Oh, gosh.
I remember...
It's the girl in the red uniform.
I haven't played or watched that one either.
Charlotte!
Charlotte, Charlotte, Charlotte.
Uh, uh, uh.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Boss-a-lot.
Oh, my gosh.
I saw the best Boss-a-lot art on Twitter the other day.
My favorite Boss-a-lot art is the young Ocelot with Boss.
And it's very...
Not very common to see.
So, often, you'll see MGS5 Ocelot with Boss.
But...
Oh, I saw.
Oh, I saw the young Ocelot with Boss.
My head hurts.
Yeah, baby, that's what I'm talking about.
It wasn't even spicy.
It was just so cute.
Okay.
Retweet?
I'll do it right now.
Let me get on my phone.
And then we'll start the game.
Oh, oh.
I did.
That's... I remember what I wanted to say earlier.
Before the stream, I watched a video of the Spirit Photography spots in Shadow Moses.
I don't think I'll remember all of them, so I will probably pull up a guide.
Oh, my God.
Just...
Sorry, I just...
I saw it again.
Okay, retweet.
Repost.
Sorry.
Is it spicy?
No, not even a tiny bit.
It's really cute, though.
Okay.
Yeah, so...
I just punched my mic.
Let me pull up a guide for the Spirit Photography.
Spirit... MGS4.
Spirit Photography.
But I think I remember a lot of them.
I think.
But probably not every of them.
Okay.
I think I'm good.
Yes.
Is the mic okay?
Mic is fine.
Actually, I punched the...
This is the mic here.
And I punched the arm that holds the mic.
It's kind of low, so...
Okay.
Let's start.
Mikey Mike.
Mikey Mike Mike.
Mike and Ike.
I think I'm over...
Let me scoot a little bit more.
So you guys can see some stuff.
Nope, nope.
Nope.
Okay.
And we got the camera.
I didn't take any photos though, did I?
Were these already on there?
Wait, I don't think I've ever seen these before.
Also, the ramen is called the Hide-chan.
It's so cute.
Woah.
Oh my gosh, old-timey.
This is so cute!
Even though it has my least favorite person ever in the world.
These are so cute.
Paying you what you're due, naniwazuni.
She's like, no!
The ramen!
Sunny and Naomi 6.
What is happening?
Oh, they're fighting over...
Let Sunny cook!
These are so cute.
Kill her, Sunny!
Oh my god, yes!
Oh my god, she can actually kill her here!
With the frying pan!
She's a genius!
Let her cook.
These are...
I think I'm going in the wrong order.
Okay, hold on.
Let's go...
Oh, she's got her little eggs.
See, there's only three eggs.
No room for you, Naomi.
Get out of the room.
Get out of the scene, Naomi.
Okay, so...
Number one...
And then they're like...
Naomi's trying to blind us.
Because she's evil.
She's trying to literally kill us.
Make us go blind.
So that we die.
Pure evil.
Evil incarnate.
And then...
Wow!
Oh my god!
Then she...
How did this happen?
Wait...
The eggs go from the pan...
Sorry, I didn't mean to change it.
To Sunny's head.
I think this is sabotage.
Naomi controlled the eggs with the nanomachines.
To burn Sunny.
Because she's evil.
She's evil.
She made them with the nanomachines.
She made them fly onto her head.
And then Sunny...
Says...
I won't let you win.
You evil woman.
Yeah, Sunny will remember this.
Oh, you can fullscreen it too.
Get back!
Wait, hold on.
Get back, Sunny!
Get back!
I won't let this evil woman get to you!
I won't let her touch you!
Get back!
Get behind me, Sunny!
Get behind me!
And...
I like this one a lot though.
I didn't notice that the ramen was called the Hide-chan.
So cute.
And look, there's only three forks.
Not four.
One for Snake, one for Otacon, and one for Sunny.
No room, no place for Naomi.
You are...
You are intruding on this peaceful life.
I want the Gacko clock so bad.
I want one.
Okay, anyway.
That was cute.
So we are loading the game.
And we are here.
Act 4 briefing.
We just...
We watched last time.
Oh, I guess we can do a little bit of a summary, right?
So...
Act 3 was where we met Big Mama.
We went to Europe...
TM.
We went to Europe, TM, and we met Big Mama who was Eva.
From MGS3.
And she was just like, hey, Big Boss is actually still alive.
He's a soupy man in a bag.
He's just...
Put your fries in the bag?
No.
Put your boss in the bag.
Proposal.
We eat Naomi into the ocean and then photoshop Minto's head over Naomi in all the pictures.
No, I don't want Sunny to hate me though.
But I would love to eat instant noodles with Sunny.
That would be so good.
Europe.
Yeah.
And we had this epic car chase.
Just like in MGS3.
It was so fun.
And I did such a good job shooting Rootin' Tootin' with auto-aim.
And then...
Then...
We...
Then we met up with...
With Ocelot.
Liquid Ocelot.
And he did bang, bang, bang.
Oh yeah, Raging Raven.
First we fought Raging Raven.
Sorry, I'm getting...
I'm only remembering the important plot points.
Yeah, we did fight Raging Raven.
Yep, yep, yep.
And then we met Liquid Ocelot.
And he went bang, bang, bang.
And there was like a big ambush from Meryl and friends.
And they were like...
They were like...
No!
And Ocelot was like, your guns don't work.
Bang, bang, bang.
And then everybody had IBS.
And then...
Except Johnny, of course.
That guy is hot.
He's smoking hot.
He rescued Meryl.
He even kissed her and then she kissed him.
Pull my devil trigger.
Yeah, he said it twice.
It was important.
It's true.
Johnny already has IBS.
The IBS master.
True.
That guy doesn't need nano...
He doesn't need man-made IBS.
He's all natural.
And so...
Unfortunately, Big Mama dies.
Sad, sad, sad, sad.
And Big Boss' body is cooked to a crisp.
He becomes...
Fried chicken.
Does that count as a spoiler?
What?
Don't worry about it.
And...
Then we are told that...
Ocelot is going to Shadow Moses.
He's gotta go fetch Rex.
And they're like, why does he gotta get Rex?
And...
What was it again?
Oh, he wants the gun.
Your new mission is to infiltrate this maid cafe and uncover the secret new mana gear.
Oh, wait.
It's the new manager.
No!
The real guy in here.
Today's my birthday!
Could you recommend a Metal Gear Solid to start playing?
Ocelot, we love the new hairstyle.
Thank you, Seymour!
Of course, you must start with Metal Gear Solid!
The first, Metal Gear Solid 1.
Happy birthday!
Congratulations!
With salutations!
Happy birthday!
May your sky stay blue!
Happy birthday to you!
Seymour, happy birthday!
Stop saying V!
V!
Thank you, Black Yoshi.
Thank you!
Yes, that.
That, that.
He was just like, I need the gun.
He's trying to get control of the Patriots, so he's just like, I gotta take out the stuff that's controlling the Patriots.
That the Patriots have control of.
So, it's just like, oh yeah!
We're gonna shoot that thing down!
With a railgun!
Okay, so we're all up to speed on the last chapter.
Look, you can see Big Mama there.
Snake got really burnt.
He got really badly hurt.
It's very sad.
Raiden is still not feeling good.
That guy is still sleepy.
Only my railgun.
Okay.
And off to Shadow Moses!
Loading, loading.
Too much Europe.
Guess so.
Harry Mann, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Minto Snake Tome and Liquid Dookie Ocelot.
What the heck?
Guys, I loaded the wrong game!
My bad.
Shadow Moses.
Shadow Moses in its prime.
That guy is coming.
So realistic.
Wow!
Our cigarettes.
Snake's favorite.
Our scope.
Wow, we got everything!
I have no weapons.
Just like the original.
We got a ration!
Very nice.
Where is that guy?
Oh, shit.
Hello?
I want to go choke him.
Maybe I can grab his butt.
Oops, wrong button.
He is fine.
No gun.
Return to your positions everybody.
We are fine.
Where is...
No gun.
It's under?
Hold on.
Don't look in here.
Call Otacon.
Actually, you can't use the...
You can't...
Codec.
Is it under here?
I'm crawling, I'm crawling, I'm crawling, crawling, crawling.
There is nothing in here.
Boop, beep, boop, bop, bop, bop.
Yeah, why would I call Otacon?
We literally just start...
We don't even know who that guy is.
Call Campbell.
I can't even open the...
I can't even open the codec.
El Gato is doing it's bestest.
OK.
My game crashed.
Everything alright Snake?
I was having that dream again.
Over here.
Shadow Moses.
It's a lot windier than I remember.
How is Otacon able to fly through here?
Nice.
Isn't that such an awesome little...
I didn't want to spoil that last week.
Because it's such a cool little...
Even like your console kind of freaks out for a bit.
Because it's a just...
It's the actual...
It's actual MGS1.
It's so awesome.
So awesome.
Twin suns.
It's really...
How can you even navigate through this?
How can you see anything?
Oh gosh Snake.
The ice on the camera lens.
This is truly a movie.
I mean Snake is fine.
Guys.
Otacon is so cool.
Yes.
Yeah.
I just slipped a little.
Grandpa.
Meet the Mark 3.
Hey honey.
Welcome to the revolution.
Thank you.
Okay.
Oh gosh.
I don't remember where these bozos are.
Bye bye.
Bye Otacon.
Oh Snake.
It's okay.
We'll get you that compress buddy.
It's so breezy.
Welcome back to Shadow Moses.
The west.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I can't see anything.
Holy moly.
I forgot how difficult this part is.
In terms of visibility.
One second.
I do want to check something real quick.
I want to see if I have a certain weapon.
And we will be using this.
In a bit.
So, sorry for the spoilers.
But I do need this.
We're going to switch out.
Because, like you said, it's unnamed here.
So I'm assuming I can kill everything.
Yeah.
So, swap.
But let me see if I have the weapon that I want.
Which one was it actually?
Hold on.
One second.
Oh yeah.
And I have my...
I have my, what's it called?
Okay.
Do I not...
Oh, maybe I can buy it.
Let me see how much it costs.
I'm not playing on Sunday.
I should have remembered to play this game on Sunday instead.
This one.
I can't afford it.
Guys.
I know I'm saving up, but...
This thing.
This gun.
This gun can take out the geckos in like two or three hits.
It's so good.
It's actually so good.
And I kind of really want it.
It's like half of our money.
It's half of our money.
I've worked so hard to get here.
Seisminto has a patriot in her weapons.
Yeah, it was the last stream.
Wait for Sunday?
No, I need it today.
What, should I just end stream and play on Sunday?
No.
Oh, gosh.
I didn't realize.
I should have scheduled this for Sunday instead.
Use the rail gun.
It takes too long to charge up.
Change the PS3 clock.
I guess I could do that.
Otsumito, see you tomorrow.
Two or three shots more than enough to kill anything that moves.
That's too good.
Mr. Resetti will yell at me.
So true.
Plus two.
That was a 10 out of 10 joke.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna change my system clock.
System settings.
One moment, please.
Spending time to save a few dollars.
More like saving a lot of dollars.
Saving so many dollars.
Wait, what?
Adjust it.
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
Set manually.
16.
Oh, yeah, baby.
Okay.
Snake.
You just...
Wait, what was it?
You...
There was a...
That was a time paradox.
The end will die of old age.
But yeah, there's nothing like that in this game, so...
I think we're okay.
Okay.
I think we're alright.
Let me pull up my...
It's more like we're saving...
I think it's 50% off, right?
Love your content, man.
Can't wait for Sussy Liquid Ocelot appears.
Oh, yeah.
Thanks, Danny.
Thank you so much.
20%.
Oh.
I guess it is a few dollars then.
Oh, sorry.
I just realized you guys can't see the game.
There we go.
You've...
Oh, that's right.
You created a time paradox.
Let's see if this works.
Load game.
Yes.
The 100,000 DP you can get later on.
We need like 4,000,000.
Yeah.
We need like so many more million thousand.
Alright.
Sorry.
I'm gonna skip the little cutscene.
I'm gonna skip the cutscene.
Skip.
Oh, yeah.
There are big sales on Act 5.
So true.
Yeah.
He's like...
Okay.
I don't remember how to...
You know, there's a way to avoid the sneak pass.
I mean, I have to sneak pass anyway.
But we'll get the gun.
Wait, what's Sunny doing?
She's hacking.
Imagine if you were on a real life race against the clock because of snake's condition.
Don't say that!
Makes me really depressed.
Look at that.
We saved 40,000 DP.
Bye.
It hurts.
It
hurts.
Oh, but it's important.
It's a good weapon to have especially in this area.
I'll show you guys.
First thing we come up against.
Where is it?
There it is.
I'll show you guys.
It's a good, good weapon.
Let me see how to use it.
So it's just like a sniper?
Okay.
Yeah, just like that.
I can't see anything.
Okay.
Oh my god, I'm lost.
That way?
Not the way.
Hell yeah, savings.
Catch my favorite act live.
I feel like this is probably everyone's favorite act.
It doesn't matter if you're a critic of the game.
I think everyone can agree that this act is just...
So good.
Sorry, I'm gonna be checking the map quite a bit.
Weee!
I heard it!
I'm scared of the geckos.
Even though I have a big gun now, I'm scared.
I see it on the map.
I'm scared.
You can use the night vision.
Let me try.
Can you?
Okay.
Sorry for everybody's eyes.
Let's try it.
And she's down.
Not even an alert.
Nothing.
What's over here?
Little rats!
Follow the rats, they're my friends.
The little rats are my friends.
Wait, I don't think I've ever noticed this area before.
Oh my gosh, it's really breezy in here.
Hello little rats!
They're my friends.
Follow the rats, they're my friends.
Where am I?
Keep going north.
Doobie.
I was playing Meow Tower.
Which is a...
What's it called?
It is a...
It's a...
Oh my gosh!
Picross!
It's Picross, but with cats.
And there was one that has different themes, obviously.
Because you make the pictures with the Picross.
The one I got latest was jumping creatures.
And it had Doobie in it!
Why can't I remember the animal now?
Jabula.
We're here!
Shadow Moses!
We were just over here earlier!
It's Snake.
I'm in front of the disposal facility.
Excellent Snake.
How's that sneaking suit working out?
I'm nice and dry, but it's a little hard to move.
Bear with it.
It's designed to prevent hypothermia.
This is Alaska, you know.
There's one up here too.
A Hind D.
What's a Russian gunship doing here?
Wow, you must be crazy to fly Hind in this kind of weather.
Who's that?
Nice to meet you Snake.
It's an honor to speak to a living legend like yourself.
It's so good!
I don't want to go in there.
No!
Wait, I didn't want to get this surveillance camera.
That's a thumbnail.
I wanted to get the other surveillance camera.
The one in here.
How do I get up there?
Do I have to drop down?
Yeah.
It's still at least you can see it.
Oh, it's also broken.
I guess they drop at the same time.
I would love to see like a...
What's it called?
A camera.
You know how like during cutscenes people will like sometimes hack games so that it will be like a free roaming camera?
I would love to see if both of them fall at the same time.
If that's the case.
Okay, so we have to hold the mantis doll.
I believe.
Our spooky doll.
And let me grab the camera.
We'll switch out...
Something.
I don't want to switch out my iPod.
The drum kit.
And we'll do the camera.
There it is.
Okay.
Spooky times happening now.
Time for spooky.
Spooky spooky!
Okay, I don't think I'm gonna remember all of these but I'll try.
First person photo mode.
Open that and press...
Oh, to switch between the first... Okay.
Where is he?
What is second person?
Oh, cool.
Do I need the sorrow doll?
Wait.
I am holding the doll.
Is it the sorrow doll instead of the mantis doll!?
No way.
I don't think I have the sorrow doll.
No!
Wait, how do you get the sorrow doll?
No, I watched... I studied that video!
No!
How do you have the dolls already?
Because I've played this game before.
I've played these games before!
Does Drebin sell it?
It's a mantis fight.
What?
I didn't even realize that he dropped more than one.
What is that?
What is Sunny doing?
Oh, she's sitting!
Oh my gosh, I thought that was like a naked body on the ground in front of her.
What is that though?
What is that?
It looks like a naked deformed body.
I don't think Drebin would sell it.
That guy doesn't sell anything.
Well, he sells these, which is kind of funny.
It's kind of funny that he sells these.
He's just like, you don't want to earn it?
You don't want to play the game good?
I
wanted to do a spirit photography.
I'm so mad at myself.
I didn't realize it wasn't the mantis doll.
Stupid.
Oh well.
Do it next year?
Well, there would have been one like right here.
There was one over there.
There's one in here.
I don't remember if there's one in there.
Can you take a pic and it might show up?
I don't know.
What is that?
Oh, thanks.
Nice.
You do not need the dolls for the ghost.
You don't?
Are you sure?
But I tried... I went to the area and there was still...
Just take the shot in the right place.
Maybe...
Holding the sorrow doll probably allows you to see it in the camera then.
I imagine.
Oh gosh, I'm not going to remember though.
Sorry.
Did you guys see?
Spooky.
Oh my gosh, it's even scarier.
Wait, is it here?
Is it here?
No!
It's a genome soldier!
Oh gosh, I don't remember where this one... I think it's like right here or something.
It's so... I was about to say sweaty.
It's so snowy.
I know there's one over here, I think.
I kept the young snake camo on.
I couldn't bear to see my favorite character so old and worn down.
Yeah, I know a lot of people feel that way.
Wait, let me get my guide.
Let me get my guide.
Look above the chaff grenade.
Oh my gosh, I can't see!
I can't see anything!
How's the bit rate in this part?
It was here.
Nothing.
What do you mean?
This guide sucks!
Absolute shit!
It says literally at the heliport, look above the chaff grenades with your cam...
Shitty ass guide.
I hate it.
They were right there.
There's nothing here!
I think I got it.
We got it!
Inside...
On the west of the heliport, enter the southernmost hangar inside or left to...
Okay, I think I got that one.
I wish it would say which ghost it is.
Northeast of the heliport, see some stairs.
Ghost is next to the camera.
A ghost!
Some stairs.
First person gameplay.
First ever done before in Metal Gear.
Stairs?
Oh, on the east.
That's right, I was trying to get this one earlier.
I was like, I know there's one over here.
I'm gonna have to delete all my failures.
No.
Higher?
This is gonna be so hard without the doll.
Maybe towards the stairs more.
No.
Next to the...
The ghost is near the camera.
This guide is so stinky!
Don't forget the ghost in the bottom right.
Oh, I tried to wink.
Get my best side!
I only have one!
Did you see him?
Okay, to the west of the main door you will find a vent.
Don't go inside yet.
Look at those guys in there!
They're rolling around!
The vent.
Above it is the ghost.
And inside, you guys, there's an even better surprise of a ghost.
I'll show you.
Oh,
there he is!
No, where did he go?
I'm getting his damn chin!
Where are you?
Where is he?
Master?
I'm getting his chin!
He's like up here.
What?
Master?
Do I need to go up more?
Back up more.
Like here?
I'm going to have so many...
So many failure photos.
Wait, I only have a hundred photos I can take.
I don't know!
I wish I could see him.
Different angle?
I'll try.
Let's go through here first.
Look at them go.
One of my favorite photos is in here, you guys.
In that room, so...
I can't wait to show you.
Oh, I don't want to go in yet.
Just kidding.
No, we won't be going in through this way.
Don't worry.
I'll be heading back outside.
But I want to get Miller first!
I wish I had the sorrow doll.
Maybe from here, you think?
Look at all the rats.
I'm scared of not having enough...
I think that counts!
He was stuck in the ceiling.
Metal Gear Snap.
Okay, we can leave.
Look, it's not even like a load.
It's all one place.
It's so crazy.
I'll check under the truck.
I know you guys want me to.
I got you.
Just like old times.
Yay!
I sold it!
I sold it for cold hard cash!
I took your nostalgia and I made 5000 DP off of it!
How do you feel about that?
And I believe those are all the photos from the heliport.
We got Master Miller.
And then I know where the next three are.
Yes, I know where the next three are.
In the hangar.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Hold on.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure I got all of them.
If you get all of them, for people who are wondering...
I'm pretty sure you get a DP boost.
MSG gone.
Change the camera view!
Yes, thank you!
What was it?
Oops.
How do you do it again?
How do you tilt up?
Oh my god.
It's like a cavern.
It's like a giant crevasse.
Come on Snake, say the line!
Say the line, Snake!
Overhead view.
That's more like it.
Yeah.
Just like old times.
Overhead view.
Yay, thank you Snake.
And thanks for the money.
Oops, I don't know why I just did that.
Okay.
Alright, I'm gonna have to be super fast here.
Wait a second.
Let me double check.
I think I know where my favorite one is, but...
Okay.
If you aim, it's so calm.
Really?
Let's try.
We'll switch it out.
We'll...
We will...
Sorry.
We'll put it back in.
Do I?
Which one is it?
23.
Oh, I see it.
I'm not used to... I'm not used to what it looks like...
Without the... What's it called?
The suppressor on it.
Oh, wrong one.
Sorry.
I'm all over the place today.
My goodness.
I'm sorry guys.
Okay.
Just like old times.
Oh, let me switch.
We'll be fine.
Look at them roll!
Look at them go!
Wait!
Shut...
Camera!
Favorite picture!
No!
Where is he?
Where are you?
Guys...
I couldn't get it.
I couldn't get my favorite one.
Where I can see ya.
There is one up here though.
It's the DARPA chief!
Oh no!
My favorite one!
I tried!
I wanna get my favorite!
I only have a limited... I mean I can always buy more chaff grenades, right?
How much are they?
Trebin, you better not be...
You better... Wait, can you sell them?
Does he sell them?
Oh gosh.
That's not good.
Oh, here they are.
I only have so many.
I only have like...
Why do they do this to me all the time?
No!
You guys, I wanted to take a picture of decoy octopus!
Octopus!
I wanted to take a picture of decoy octopus.
Top left corner.
Top left.
I would have to do another chaff grenade though.
Please stop backseating you guys.
Please, please, please.
I'm playing the game.
Don't...
I don't know why there are so many backseaters of people telling me what to buy and what to get today.
Can you kill them?
I mean, yeah, but like...
It's kind of annoying, no?
There are so many in here.
Let's see.
If I snipe them... Or not snipe them.
If I...
Let's see.
I don't know why I'm switching everything up today.
I don't know what's wrong with me.
If I get them with the suppressor...
Wouldn't you need chaff anyway?
I'm basically like...
Basically like these sections.
They're rolling autobots.
Yes.
Oh yeah, see?
They're too scary.
They're so scary.
Andrangos, thanks for the 20 gifts.
Did I get the one near the tank?
Yep.
I got it really, really...
Oh my gosh.
Go
over, then aim for the neck.
I got him.
Aim for what?
I need more bullets though.
What does this take?
What do you use?
Purchase ammo.
Pricey.
Thank you.
I need more bullets.
Now Otacon is backseating.
I know.
But that guy is always backseating.
What do I do about decoy octopus?
You know what?
Oh gosh, this area, I don't know like any of where the...
I think I'm gonna give up, you guys.
I'm not gonna have enough camera.
I'm not gonna have enough film.
I only have 60 more shots.
And if I mess up again...
There is a lot of places.
A lot of places.
Snakes don't belong in Alaska.
This is where we fight Vulcan Raven.
Sad.
Is there anything else around here?
Or am I crazy?
I think there was one above this rock and there is one over there.
If I had the sorrow doll, I would be much more confident about it, but...
Crazy to think how small this little field is.
Right?
What's up here?
Thank you.
There might be an iPod song.
I think I got it, right?
I think I already got it.
Game makes you realize how tiny Shadow Moses is.
When you don't have the load times in between and...
Who are you?
Fans.
Deep Throat!
Deep Throat.
Wow!
Twin Peaks!
Sorry, decoy octopus.
I tried.
I really wanted to show you guys.
There is a picture of decoy octopus.
I have to.
It's like my favorite guy.
Get in there.
I know there is a photo.
I'll get some of the ones that I remember though, that I like.
There is a couple that I like.
This is so fun.
Like I remember up here.
There is this one.
I think it's here.
It's like a pair of super freaky eyes.
Look at it.
Where did he go?
See him?
There is a restaurant called Twin Peaks.
Yeah, I've always wanted to go.
I've never been.
There is no fellas in here, right?
I don't think so.
Oh, I remember there is a guy.
I don't know why I'm still trying.
I still want to try.
Hello.
I don't see any enemies around here.
Yeah.
I want to go.
I want to go to the commander's office.
Are you alright, Snake?
You are sure huffing and puffing a lot.
There is something tiny there.
There is a warhead storage facility friend right here.
He is just doing his rounds.
See him?
Did you see it?
He is old, man.
I know.
Related Happy Valentine's Mito!
Hope you were able to get a bunch of chocolate on sale.
Could you please tell us...
You tolerate us?
Everybody...
I tolerate you.
And I'll tolerate you for the rest of my afterlife.
Oh no, I can't open.
We got the fam.
She tolerates us.
I wish there was a good place I could put myself so you could see everything.
There is just so much going on in this UI, you know?
Pipi!
Thank you, thank you!
Yep!
You're making him throw up!
Why won't you...
Otacon, tell me at the computer!
48273 Otacon!
Rude!
Thank you!
Okay!
I never noticed that you can see through here.
There is like even more in there.
Wow, we never go in there before.
48273 I'm not good with numbers, you guys.
I think I have a dic-calcula.
Whatever it's called.
Look, you can see it in here too!
Is this thing safe?
I can't believe they won't even let you go to B1.
Actually, while we're in here...
Oh, that's the wrong thing.
Camouflage.
I will put on...
No, what am I doing?
Face, there we go.
Should we do young or should we do MGS1?
Second floor basement.
Which one should we do?
MGS1?
Okay, MGS1 is resounding.
Resounding fanfare.
Campbell.
So cursed, the Campbell.
Look, I did that!
I did this.
That was me.
I did that and then I could go over here and I could listen.
I could say...I could say...
Otacon!
Sky, welcome to my motion!
Thank you!
Oh, I did not even see that.
Oh my goodness.
This place is...
It looks so trashed.
Because of me.
There's even little rats.
Hello?
Everything looks exactly like I remember it.
Except for that wall way in back anyway.
I still can't believe how much damage you caused in such a small space.
Look at him.
Look at him with this little fist on his face.
Reminiscing.
Otacon, you're not wearing glasses.
Please.
You're embarrassing yourself.
Didn't make much of a bang, huh?
Hardly.
Switchboard is still intact.
You're right.
The wiring past the switch circuits could still be live.
Reflex.
Do you guys do that if you wear glasses?
Do you accidentally sometimes push them up when you don't have them?
Phantom glasses.
I remember getting stuck in an elevator one time and waiting almost an hour to get out of it and now I have a fear of elevators.
At least Shadow Moses' work.
You do?
I decided that when I go to Japan...
Wow, what a small little detail.
Did you guys see me kick that?
Oh my gosh, I'm destroying the documents.
I'm getting rid of the evidence.
Oh yeah, I guess we could crawl through here, huh?
Um...
When I go to Japan...
During... In March, since I have the collab cafe and everything...
I will... I will get new glasses.
I've decided.
When are you leaving for Japan again?
The end of this month.
I'll only be there for about a week.
So...
I don't remember where any of the guys... Actually, I do remember there will be one here.
As for anything else in this hallway, I don't remember.
Freaky...
This is like... This hallway is one of my favorite...
One of my favorite parts of the game.
What happened to the bodies?
That's so true.
Maybe the rats ate them.
Probably, right?
I
did that.
No, I didn't.
Hurt me more, Snake!
Bones and all?
Bones and all.
Oh, shit.
I forgot the code.
Two, eight, three... No.
Seven, three.
Seven, two...
Four, eight, seven, two, three.
Thank you.
Four, eight...
Wait.
Four, eight, two, seven, three.
Okay.
Snake!
Uppies!
You can use 1-4-8-9-3 for a thousand DPs.
There's secret codes?
Is that real?
Snake!
Man has no expressions.
What?
Don't be a liar, Otacon.
Wait, Kyoma, is that real?
Are you gonna... Am I getting one guide for real?
Am I getting one guide?
Yes, there's a hidden password.
I also work on Otacon's computer.
That could either give driven points or iPod songs.
We need the points.
It's real?
Okay, Kyoma, I'm trusting you with my afterlife right now.
One, four...
Eight, nine, three...
I didn't want Otacon to think we were old, so I was truly gonna put in the correct number, but...
iPod songs though.
It's okay, we can come back and get them.
That sounded like it gave us some money!
Look at him smiling.
He's like, okay, you got this.
Snake, I think maybe your memory... Don't worry, I'm sure I can remember it.
Is the money worth it?
Is the money worth that cutscene?
It's so sad.
How did he... I think your memory too, Otacon.
You're literally the one who told us earlier.
I think...
You're the one calling the kettle black, huh?
You're the one!
It's such a shitty cutscene, it makes you feel so bad.
Otacon making us feel bad for no reason.
I forgot too, Snake.
Even though I literally told you five minutes ago.
And I was allegedly the one to... You remembered it!
I don't understand!
I like how sandy Snake is.
The stain is still there.
It's my dad's favorite act.
Hot dog, hot dog.
Zooms in on pee, pee, pee, piss, pee, pee, piss.
Did Otacon have a Playstation game?
Well, we did not save your pants.
That's why she's such a bitch.
Board Game Error!
Yeah!
I got mine actually!
I'm glad you got yours.
Yeah!
Because she's evil!
She wanted to steal Otacon's body.
Disgusting.
Why does he look like he's covered in sand?
It's an image taken a few hours ago by a surveillance camera up ahead.
Oh my god!
What a surprise!
He's frosting.
It would melt though if it were snow.
Right?
Oh come on.
Clean.
Naomi is the beast.
So true!
Check the P-State with the solid I-Infrared on.
Wait, I think I do remember this.
Level 2!
Every time this song starts my heart aches.
Yeah!
We got the money, money baby!
We got the money honey!
Press X to remember.
My friend.
He should have been killed, but he's still alive.
Are you an Otaku too?
After Zanzibar!
Look at him heavy breathing as he sees this spot.
It's okay Snake.
It's like nothing has changed.
No one has vacuumed this spot in 9 years.
It's still wet.
A little compress.
Actually, let me use the compress.
Do I still have it in my inventory?
There we go.
Yeah!
Yeah, he did.
Well, I guess in Twin Snakes he had the GameCube, right?
Let's see.
I have noodles.
Right here everybody!
Are you guys ready to see the man, the myth, the legend?
If I can get it correctly.
3, 2, 1...
Did you see it?
There is one I think here.
I don't remember which one this is though.
Oh!
It's a...
Baker.
And then I think there is one here.
See, I told you guys.
I really...
Ah, I got it.
I did try really hard to remember these.
I really did.
Nice.
And that's everything in here.
Let's go.
This one is kind of spooky.
Ready?
Geckos.
We got geckos.
I don't know who that is.
It's maybe one of the beauties.
Maybe a raging raven or... I don't know actually.
Spooky lady.
Okay, now we go.
Wife?
Who?
Yours?
It's my wife.
Don't worry about it.
You know, she was just super important in this game.
Okay.
Oh my gosh!
Kojima is gone!
Welcome to Mambushu!
Thank you!
That's so funny.
Okay.
Oh, from here?
I'm kind of nervous about these rooms.
I'm not gonna lie.
I'm not gonna worry about the camera because...
It's kind of...
It's gonna get a little messy for me maybe.
I got it.
Uh...
I told you man.
Getting this gun was like the best purchase.
Getting this gun is absolutely insane.
I told you.
You need it for the geckos.
It's absolutely just craziness.
Instantly pays for itself.
That's what I'm saying.
Speedrun gun.
Yeah, for real.
Snowfield and communications tower.
Was there anything...
Any ghosts here?
I don't remember.
Actually, I don't think I remember.
Tower.
I'm full on so many things.
I wish I could at least sell them for money.
No,
that's not what... There we go.
We won't need this for now.
Where is my...
Twin barrel.
We're going all...
And I think... I can't believe these are still ID locked.
Yeah, we'll just... I don't want to use my... I don't want to accidentally use it.
I don't think I would accidentally use it, but you know what I mean.
Oh, it's only 8 DP.
Boy.
Wait, I should unlock these.
Why haven't I yet?
Yeah, why not unlock them?
A lot of the other things I don't really need, you know.
The javelin is insane.
Holy moly!
Look at that thing!
Oh my gosh, how am I supposed to carry that?
But I feel like with the... With these, I think they're fine to...
Okay, I don't know if I'll use that, but...
Javelin indoors.
The doll is easy to find this time.
It is!
I feel like it would be the opposite, because it's so... I can barely see anything!
I am, though.
I am going to switch.
Sorry, everybody.
We're switching back to Old Snake.
If you went to the area with the dwarf geckos, you could get the song from Zone of the Enders 2, Beyond the Bounds.
The area with the dwarf geckos.
The first area?
The hangar?
The tank?
I don't remember if I grabbed it before.
We've gotten the thermal goggles yet.
I know there's a way to cheese this fight, where you can go to an area...
Sorry for everyone.
We're about to do a boss fight, if you couldn't tell.
It's just crazy that you fight two snipers here.
But if you have ammo for the shotgun...
If not, I can always buy it during the fight.
It's no problem.
Yeah, it's like zero.
It's okay.
I think we'll be using the Mosin mostly.
But I don't remember what area you go to cheese it.
I don't remember.
Oh well.
Those nostalgic doggy cries.
So recently... I don't know what it is, but I've recently been wanting a dog.
Which I'm not a dog person at all.
But just a little bit.
I've been watching some dog videos.
And I saw a video the other day of a dog and a cat getting along.
A dog does not fit my afterlife style at all.
But I've kind of just been wanting a dog.
Big dog or little dog?
Like a medium sized dog.
I probably won't get one.
But this is like a lot of work having a dog.
But...
Of course I would name him D-Dog.
Like a hundred percent.
Stop!
Don't do that right now.
I will have to possess you.
Chihuahua?
No, not a Chihuahua.
That's me.
That's me in this game.
Absolute me.
No, don't do that.
Would your dog and dad be friends?
Friends.
Sad lady.
No, no!
Oh, snake.
Not the time.
Oh, no.
Oh, snake.
Not the time, snake.
Snake, I need you to...
Cry for me.
How many wolves does she have inside her?
Oh,
snake.
I think having that big metal ring on your back really doesn't help with the...
With the impact, you know?
That thing probably hurts a ton.
Oh, I'm crying.
You guys, I forgot to show you something.
I'll show you later.
Or what if I just did it right now?
Oh my god, there's geckos too?
Wait, I forgot.
Not geckos, froggies.
And die.
Okay,
baby.
Let's get rid of this M4.
Goodbye, goodbye, goodbye.
Goodbye, goodbye.
Switch it out for...
MK2.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Sorry for night vision.
What do you mean, what?
Is that her?
Wait.
Who is that?
How do you know?
Did they wake up?
Oh, I have no more ammo.
Trying to get these guys out first.
Reload.
God, there's so many of them.
There's so many of them.
Trying to take care of them first.
I don't know if I can get her from there.
Will they wake up?
I'm scared.
Should I be killing them instead?
I hear her.
I hear her too.
It's kind of spooky.
Spooky.
Eventually...
Boo!
No!
Okay.
Where is she anyway?
Ma'am?
What are you crying at?
Oh my god.
What the hell?
I'm getting hijacked?
That didn't help me at all.
What's happening?
Stop!
Stop hijacking me!
Oh my god, she's so close.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, run!
Oh my...
That person should be dead.
Holy shit!
I don't quite remember how to do this fight.
Like, I hear her everywhere, you know?
Bad timing.
Wait, who's coming?
Sorry.
Screw this fight!
Oh my god.
Where are you?
Oh my gosh.
How do I get her though?
Holy moly.
Where did she go?
Oh, there she is right there.
Where'd she go?
Oh, she's running.
Nice shot, really?
No,
no!
Please!
There we go.
Madam!
We did get some good damage with that one shot though.
So if I can just do that a couple times, we'll be alright.
Right?
Yeah!
Oh no, they're waking up.
You can see them.
Starting to get up.
Where is she?
Good shot, thank you.
I wish these guys would just
go...
Oh my gosh, stop!
Stop waking them up!
I wish I could tell where she was.
Oh my god, no!
This camouflage.
Maybe I should become more camouflaged.
Now it's only negative five.
How can you see me in this snowstorm?
Where is she?
Yep.
I hear something moving, but...
Oh, there she is!
Damn it!
I'm out of ammo, I think.
What does it take?
Wait, what does it take?
Can I just get the...
No, this is...
Hold on.
I'll find it.
Did I pass it?
There we go.
Any of these?
We'll just get the normal ones.
Yeah, we'll just get the normal ones.
Should be okay.
Like twenty...
Pieces?
Should be okay.
Oh my god.
Did I not...
Oh, okay, we did do damage.
I was about to say.
Hello?
Oh my gosh.
It's not a good hiding.
It's not a good hiding spot.
Oh gosh.
Please.
Good night.
Hey, who?
Hey, you!
Please.
Please go to sleep.
Thank you.
Even with those helmets on, you can hear him snoring.
Is that her?
Yes.
Oh my gosh, that's a pretty far shot, but...
Is it too far?
Okay, let me keep going.
Caution from who?
Bullet drop.
Oh, come on.
I saw you.
I saw your head.
And they're gone.
Oh god.
Oh god!
She's on this side.
She's over here.
Damn it!
I didn't hear it.
I didn't hear it rev up.
Can I kill her here?
That would be so great.
Does she know where I am?
Okay, I'm high...
I'm high stealth now.
She's on the walls!
Okay, hold on.
Let me get my ration.
Come on, Snake, get up!
We're fine!
Oh shoot.
No, it's not.
Okay, let's go find her again.
If she would just stay still.
That flip though.
I know.
I can't tell.
No, you didn't.
I don't know where she is.
Can I get a hint?
Wait, no, that's not her.
Wait, yes it is.
Nice.
Alright, we're close.
Something just what?
What?
What did something just do?
Nothing, just nothing.
Yeah, just your imagination.
I can see so well.
You're so scary.
Oh shoot.
I think that lady is gonna...
No?
Maybe not.
Okay.
Oh, yep, she is.
Whatever, it's fine.
Don't worry about it.
Must have been the wind.
Just the wind!
Let's go find her.
I think maybe like two more?
One if I'm lucky.
One if I'm really good.
If I get like a good headshot, I think.
I hear her panting.
Who saw me?
What do you mean that sound?
Oh, there she is.
Got her!
I love slime girls!
And slimy girls.
She didn't notice.
Why couldn't this be the terrain we were playing in, huh?
Madam, your rump is...
It's mightier than these hills we've been fighting on.
Oh, yeah!
A tiny little gun snake.
The trophy first, yes.
Thank you.
Oh, no!
She has babies!
Oh, I also hear the cries of babies.
Uh-oh.
Stop it!
Stop crying!
My cat at 6am.
Please stop crying!
My cat when he's crying at 6am to be fed.
I'm an owl.
Go away.
Nevermind.
Don't come any closer.
That's me also right before stream.
Stop crying!
No babies!
Stop getting pregnant!
I'm sorry.
Me when I'm one minute late for stream.
Forgive me.
It's my party.
Cry if you need to.
She's a dog.
She's got that dog in her.
Damn.
Cat.
You...
I...
Oh my gosh.
I can't see anything.
Hold on, lady.
Where's your statue?
That's a ration.
That's a...
Fig...
Oh, figure!
I found it.
Don't worry.
I'll change my gun.
Yeah!
Crying wolf doll.
An action figure of crying wolves.
Customized battle suit.
Oh my gosh.
She's fast.
Hold on.
Let me...
Actually, which gun did it switch out?
Oh, I need to buy more V-Ring.
We'll wait until we get to the special zone.
Oh gosh!
Why is she so fast?
Stay away from me, lady!
Women scare me!
Keep...
Yeah, she going.
She's going.
Yeah, we're getting her to the special zone.
I feel I should buy...
Hold on.
Before I forget though.
I'm gonna buy...
I'm going to buy ammo.
So that I don't forget...
What?
Bullets.
For my...
We need the V-Ring.
Wait, did I just pass it?
Yes, I did.
Let's do...
Let's do 40.
Look
at the way she shuffles.
Hold on.
I'm not ready.
What was that?
Oh god!
The way she glows.
She's got that aura.
Stay away from me, crown beauty!
I know she wants me so bad.
You took out these trees.
Don't worry, I'm not gonna do anymore.
It's creepy.
Stay away from me, lady!
Lady!
The way she like shuffles along with her arms.
It's too fun.
Oh no!
Oh no no!
I need to look where I'm going.
No!
Not the dog!
She walks faster than you run.
I know, she's just built different.
Crying wolf.
What's your favorite song, lady?
What do you want to listen to?
Oh, let me also...
Equip...
My iPod.
Oh, I do have it equipped.
I'm so smart.
Sunny chilling in the corner while I'm fighting for my...
Wait!
This is scripted.
I forgot to show you guys...
Oh, I can show you guys now.
Wait, I was gonna show you guys earlier.
Now that we have a second.
Ready?
I have two things to show you.
Because my papa Celia is a genius.
Oh, sorry.
I didn't mean to do that.
It's gonna be all messed up now.
No!
I messed up my thing.
Okay, that's better.
Okay, ready?
Number one.
Dark mode.
Dark mode, dark mode.
This is so cool.
And then also number two.
I'm thinking Miku, Miku.
Maybe I'll say this way for the rest of the stream.
Anyway, back to the sex fest.
iPod, music, songs...
And we're going to...
My favorite.
Oishi Touhan Seikatsu!
You wanna pose for me?
You nervous?
Big fan of Mint-kun.
Yeah?
Oh damn, I was too slow.
I was too slow.
Is it just laughing octopus that does the sexy poses for us?
Damn it, I'm such an idiot.
There it is!
Yeah!
Okay, dance for me.
Dance for me.
Okay.
Yeah!
What is this?
This is...
Metal Gear!
Dark mode.
Minto Miku kinda hits the floor with the moans in the background.
Don't say that!
BB bosses can be killed lethally when they are in beast mode.
There's no penalty for using lethal on these bosses.
Only need to...
No...
No!
I need to be non-lethal so I can get their statue.
Holy rumpus.
But I also just wanna be non-lethal because it makes more sense to be non-lethal.
Because they are still alive.
They become baby mode.
Alright, Rebin.
The real gun.
Oh, I already had it but thank you.
Alright, everybody get comfortable.
I wonder what Kanjumbo is.
Nah.
I hope nothing.
I want him to be like this naturally.
Isn't that more interesting?
If someone is just naturally insane.
Don't actually go to sleep!
Her baby brother.
I've always wanted a brother.
I've always wanted a baby brother.
Hatsune Miku?
If you guys think this is the end of the act, there's more peak incoming.
There's actually so much more to this act so...
Don't go!
There's way more left.
Peak incoming.
We haven't even reached it.
I think we're about halfway.
Literally mean it?
Every stream?
The wolf.
Oh my god.
By one wolf?!
Oh.
By one lady?
She was cleansed by you.
If the cries she heard of children on the battlefield have been silenced, it's because of you.
You ought to be proud.
Three down, one to go.
All that's left is Mantis.
But you should know Snake, she's been controlling all the other beasts.
She's the beast of beasts.
Don't let her get her hooks in you.
I won't.
See you around, Snake.
See ya!
There are two wolves inside you.
One of them is crying.
One of them is...
Is a baby.
Okay.
Watching Minplay, this is like nostalgia inside memories.
Going back to Zanzibar.
Inside Yuletide.
CS4.
One of the memories here is my favorite...
Probably my favorite line in Metal Gear Solid 1.
And almost maybe in all of Metal Gear.
No!
My little heart!
It's okay, she's still alive.
I kept her alive, don't worry, she's still alive.
She's still alive.
Bye bye.
Her little toes is dragging in the snow.
She's gonna get frostbite.
Mark 3, too cute.
Sorry, sorry.
Oops.
Oh wait, wrong thing.
Weapons.
Oh gosh.
For the upcoming fight.
I don't quite remember how to do it, but I know I'm just gonna equip some of this stuff.
In fact, what if I do the shotty, but...
Not as...
A railgun.
Even if you're a freak, my Kamiyoshi is a freak.
Yeah!
Thanks for the superchat.
We'll just do it not as a trunk.
Alright, I believe...
Is it here?
Did you see her?
Sniper wolf.
Hello.
Hi puppy, hi.
Hi puppy, hi puppy, hi puppy.
Oh, it's like a pet dog.
It's so...
I hate kind of exploring this area because it's just...
Insanely difficult to see.
Oh, here it is.
I'll tell you.
Okay!
Okay.
That's one of my favorite lines.
In almost all of Metal Gear maybe.
What was she fighting for?
What am I fighting for?
What are you fighting for?
If you make it through this, I'll tell you.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
Sorry, we don't want to go to the blast furnace yet.
Oh, hello dog.
I love that line.
It makes me so emo-y.
Emotional.
I can't see shit.
Is it over there?
I'm gonna be a guest, right?
At MGS Con.
Happening this year.
And...
Amanda, the organizer...
She was like, what do you wanna...
Did you guys want blue Minto?
Blinto.
But...
She was like, is there anything you wanna do?
Like a panel or something?
She suggested a...
Like a karaoke panel.
I was like, that might be fun.
If I do that...
I was like, okay, I have to learn the best is yet to come.
I have to actually...
Learn the language.
Where is it?
Hold on.
How do I zoom out?
There we go.
Did I pass it?
It's over that way?
Or is it that...
I think it's that loopy area.
It's a loop loop.
But I'm also trying to get some more...
I'm looting, you know.
I'm a little loot gab.
What am I fighting for is ruined for me because of Mega Man.
It's English dub.
This is not Mega Man.
Oh, I
went the wrong way.
This way.
Gosh.
I know there was stuff up there, but honestly I just don't feel like going all the way up there.
That is not Mega Man.
The other side.
Wait, is it over here?
Can I even get through here?
Sorry.
Oh my god.
Okay, I guess it's the other side.
Sorry, I'm looking for the hindy.
I'm looking for the hindy, you guys.
Remember, you can find it through here.
No, but you wish.
You wish, so...
I just wish it wasn't terrible to see.
I wonder how is the bitrate on this.
Can you guys even see anything?
Is it impossible for you as well?
It's good?
Really?
I can't remember where I've checked and not.
What was that?
Only in MGS1 can you just see it.
But like, from beyond the wall...
But here you can go up to it.
I love my little wolf gang.
Amadeus.
Mozart.
What's down there?
Oh, that's not what I meant to push.
Sorry.
Wow, I never...
What?
You can make it 3D!
I didn't know you could do that.
What?
I know it literally says it right there.
Change angle.
But I didn't know.
Change focus.
But it's a wall.
We can't get beyond there.
That's so cool.
It shows.
Wait a second.
Was there...
Was there a hole in...
Oh my god, we went all the way around for no reason.
Oopsie.
Alright, we can go now.
Bye dogs!
Oh, I gotta change the disc.
Nah.
Oh my god, I'm so mad.
The dogs want to come with.
Can I bring them?
To the blast furnace.
Damn it.
He's so grumpy.
I'm scared of this area, you guys.
Look at this.
There's so many little guys around.
There's too many little guys around.
Scary.
This is why I need to have trap grenades.
It's so frosty in the blast furnace now.
I don't think you can even call it a blast furnace.
The music in here is great though.
Wow, look at our camo.
Look at that.
Back it up.
Ration.
Do I not...
Oh, I'm full on rations?
I'm too good at this game.
Yeah!
I don't think I really need to loot anything in here.
I don't even remember if there's any...
I truly don't remember if there's any...
Is there some ammo down there?
If there's any ghost photos.
But I've already missed so many, so might as well not give it up.
I give up.
I give up!
Change my disc.
Oh, not the items.
Yeah.
I only have three.
Okay.
Get the bait ration.
Alright.
There is none.
Not you.
You.
Here we go.
Just gonna throw it right down there.
The bait ration.
I don't need it.
I have too many rations.
Otacon.
Do you see that laser beam?
Do you see that...
Oh, shit.
Oh, for god's sake.
Well, I had to activate that anyway.
I'm trying to remember.
I think I will probably be using all my trap grenades here.
I think...
I think I'll be using all of them.
Northwest corner.
Do you need any for Act 5?
I don't think so.
No, I don't think so.
God, this scared me.
Loud.
Run!
We fought.
Yippee!
Fellas.
Let's give her the 10 gift then.
You killed my benefactor.
And sent my brother home a cripple.
I vowed revenge.
But I can't go yet.
I still have a job to do.
British accent, don't go.
They use the twin snakes lines for this, don't they?
Oh, shit.
I forgot about this guy.
Actually, can I...
Oh, you guys can't see it.
Look at this.
See that tiny little dot?
You're kind of blocking it too on the... You can see it under the chat.
But that tiny little dot...
This room is also kind of painful.
I know there's
a guy down there, I'm pretty sure.
I don't need you.
But I'm crawling through.
Stop scanning!
Just in case.
Oh wait, maybe he's further.
I think I should chaff.
I think I should chaff in here, maybe.
The cows are here.
I only have one left.
How do I only have one?
Oh yeah, because I used the second.
But I think actually this might be the last part that I needed.
Save your chaffs!
This area is so scary though.
Does Drebin sell?
No, he does not.
Are you kidding me?
This area is terrifying.
And there's cow.
Look at them!
Yeah, I really don't need it for the next act.
Like I could use it, but...
I feel like with the dwarf geckos in this act, it's way worse.
I think I'm just going to use it.
Sorry everybody who said don't use it, but I'm going to use it.
I feel better using it.
Wait, oh shit, how do I get over there?
Oh shit, how do I get over there?
Maybe I wasted it!
Guess we're killing everything again.
Yep.
It's unarmed, we're fine.
Probably.
It's unarmed!
It's fine!
We made it!
No witnesses!
Oh there's a spooky one here.
Hold on, I'll show you.
Oh, camera.
Right here.
Ready?
Spooky lady.
Woman jumpscare.
Oh my god.
I got baited.
I got absolutely baited.
Do they stop falling or...
How do they even see me?
Guys, I don't think they're stopping.
I can smell you.
Oh my gosh, I can't even get through!
Let me through!
Guys, this might be kinda tricky.
Oh my god!
Snake!
Worst place to...
Oh my god.
Just run.
We could farm for DP there.
What if we did just a little bit of that?
You look so good with the dark outfit.
Thanks AndreyGhost!
Glad you like it.
Auto-Aim?
Did I kill all of them?
Did
I kill them all?
Can I get the bird?
Bird.
Such a good weapon.
This is so awesome.
Oh shit, I just realized our health though.
Snake, you okay?
Are you stressed?
We're okay.
Let's have some noodles.
Oh wait, we need the nanya.
You know what that looks like?
That looks like the little area you run through in MGS3.
The underground area.
Is there anything over here anyway?
Nope.
Oh, I almost missed this one.
Such thing as boundless slaughter.
There is always an end to it.
But you are different.
The path you walk on has no end.
The killing will never end.
It's a future without hope.
Hear me, Snake!
My spirit will be watching you.
I'm healing a little bit too.
We got our nanya.
We got our health.
We're doing so good.
Good job guys.
Now for the next fight.
Should I be lethal?
I really wanna use lethal.
I'm looking forward to using lethal.
I'm gonna use lethal.
Railgun?
No.
I think it will be way too slow.
The lift.
It's so cool.
Little bit of lethal as a treat.
I gotta potty.
Gotta go use little ghost's room.
Oh boy.
Especially cause I gotta be in tip-top shape for...
For freaking out.
Oh, the Mark III!
Hello.
Zoom in.
Zoom.
Send her up.
Rex once stood here.
Remember back in the day, every easter egg, game facts...
Like...
They claim that Darth Vader's helmet is in the cutscene hidden in the rubble.
I'm 99% sure that's not true.
Why did they claim this?
That's so funny.
I miss those old game facts hoaxes.
You don't get those much anymore, huh?
It's such like a product of it's time.
Oh boy!
No, bye!
Rex.
Oh, Snake's face.
It's like...
There's some more spirit photography we can even get in this room.
Uh-oh.
He looks so sad.
He's like...
The railgun!
This...
I can't.
I can't watch this.
This display.
This disgusting display!
She's tickling his tit!
What the fuck is wrong with you?
She's so...
Oh my god, the little snow on his mustache.
Why?
I don't understand.
She didn't act this way the entire game until now and she's just like...
Oh, shoot.
Hold on, men.
I really gotta go to the little ghost's room, you guys.
I'm so sorry.
I'm sorry I had too much tea.
And I'm gonna grab some more tea, too.
Well, I'm out.
Little break, little break.
It's been over two hours.
We get a little intermission.
Intermission, intermission.
Break before the big fight.
And even after this fight, there's more.
So, here, I'll even let you guys see.
There you go.
You guys can look while I...
While I astral project.
Okay, BRB.
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
Let me also write...
I forgot.
I forgot that I never changed it.
No.
God.
There we go.
Alright, alright, alright.
Okay, I might be a few minutes because I'm gonna make my tea and...
go to the little ghost's room.
So, maybe like a minute or so.
Two minutes.
Two minutes max.
Okay, BRB.
Okay, okay.
Are you guys ready to fight a ramp?
Why is she blue?
I like it.
It looks good, right?
Are we complaining?
Are you ready to fight a ramp?
Wow, I just noticed the map.
Oh my gosh, look.
Wait, once the donut goes away...
You can see a little... Like you can see the outline of Rex.
Okay.
Where are you?
Where is he?
Oh my god.
Don't sound like that, please.
Ouch, ouch.
Oh my god.
This guy sucks so much.
Oh, it does nothing.
Okay, hold on.
Ouch.
Oh my god, it does no damage.
He sucks so much.
Okay, okay.
I tried to roll.
Yeah,
let's use a different gun.
Disappointing.
Wait, I can just unload on him.
Duh.
I can just unload on him.
Wait, hold on.
Hold on, mister.
I hate auto-aim so much.
Nevermind, auto-aim is great.
Sir, you are kinda currently not winning the...
Bye!
Ouch.
I don't care.
I don't care if I'm unloading all on you.
Is this the Patriot?
Absolutely.
He's done!
Oh my god, I might be done.
No, it's not my best, but it's getting the job done.
That's for sure.
Where is your motivation?
Oh shoot.
Wait, uhm...
Do I have it in my items?
Items?
Shoot, let's get rid of the nanya.
Oh shoot.
Where is the yellow dead cell?
Right?
Actually, we have that.
Oh shoot.
I was too good at the game.
Wait, come here.
Come here.
Man, I wish I could use my Patriot.
It's no use.
Do I have to do it non-lethally?
I don't?
Ok, let's do it again.
Oh shoot.
Please, please.
Ok, hold on.
Ok.
Oh shoot.
Oh wait, I got it.
Wait, this is a CQC gun.
Grab him!
Oh shoot.
I need to crash him.
Sorry guys.
What's the button?
Oh my god.
What is it again?
Oh shoot.
No, no, no.
I just punched him.
I can.
Oh triangle.
Come here, man.
Guys, I think maybe I don't know how to play the game.
Oh my god.
God, this son of a bitch.
I'm so bad at the game.
Come here.
What?
No, it says it's a CQC gun.
So I should be able to.
I'll try it with the operator though.
Where did he go?
Guys, triangle is not doing anything.
Guys, it's not doing anything.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
I'm dying now.
Maybe I should just restart so I don't waste all my...
Where are you?
Grab.
Wait, no, I was asking...
Guys, I was asking how to grab, not how to do the triangle.
It prompts you to triangle.
No, I thought you meant triangle to grab.
This health is still too high?
Seriously?
Oh, there it is.
That's so unlucky.
Hold on, I'm just gonna restart.
Just kill me.
I don't want to waste all my...
I don't want to waste all my rations.
Tactical retreat everybody.
It's a tactical retreat.
Well, I have my tea.
Oh, I love this one though.
It's so messed...
Beautiful!
What a way to go.
Again, again!
Wow, that was so good.
See, now we have all our rations.
We can switch to the patriot and we'll be so good.
Oh, I already have it equipped because I...
I know.
And I have... Oh, you gotta switch out the Nenya.
Oh, Nenya.
Oh my god, I've been calling it Nenya this entire time.
Where did I get Nenya from?
Why didn't you guys correct me?
Where is he?
Oh, where is he?
This is the easiest way to do it.
OK, we need you to not die up there though.
Come on!
Oh, grab him!
Grab him!
OK,
let me try switching to the operator.
Come here!
Grab him!
There we go!
And... Injecto!
I thought that because it said CQC for the patriot it would work.
There.
Now you're a mere mortal, like the rest of us.
But can you kill this mere mortal?
I thought it because it said CQC.
That's so misleading.
Oh my goodness.
Uh-oh.
What does that mean?
Why do they sound like...
Slice and dice!
I like how they sound like cicadas.
Wow!
Who could be our mysterious savior?
That's not the line.
You ready for this?
Sunny gave me the go-ahead.
After seeing this game, Revengeance is like the perfect...
perfect sequel for Raiden.
In terms of gameplay.
You know?
Sunny is a good girl.
How about it, undying man?
Care to die too?
Sorry, but I can't die just yet.
He's so cool.
Wow.
Oh my gosh.
Blunt Cut Queen.
Okay, I have a good gun for that now.
I got you.
Oh, I mean...
That works too?
Get him in there.
Oh no, I just realized.
I forgot to get...
Can I still get the Spirit Photographer here?
Is it lined up after this game?
It's actually technically the final game.
No way.
Before Revengeance, right?
Sensual man.
He wants Raiden.
I mean, look at those claws.
All the way around.
Oh my god.
I think I'll probably save Revengeance though for after 5.
Even though it's not technically release order, but it's not part of the story, so...
Like, you know, the solid story.
So I think it's okay to save it.
You know what time you can duel out of release order?
Oh my god.
Sorry, Otacon.
Hold on one second.
I think I missed it.
Oh, I wanted to show you guys the Spirit Photography.
I completely forgot.
I got so into...
Vamp.
Shoot.
It's okay.
There's one, so I'll tell you.
At the foot of...
At the foot of Rex, you can find...
Gray Fox.
And then in the mouth of Rex, you can find Liquid.
So that's kind of fun, I think.
I can't... Oh, I'm on Playboy for some reason.
Why did I get that?
Yep, you're welcome.
Oh my god.
Can I hit that?
No.
Maybe this one?
Maybe one more?
There we go.
Oh, that's...
Actually, I wonder if you can do it here.
Let's try.
Where's my camera?
No, camera mode not allowed.
Oh shoot.
Sorry guys.
Sorry I missed the...
Why are you not going down?
Oh my god.
Tanky.
Just what?
I'm watching.
Can I get him through the hole?
I'm not!
Get him in the butt!
Oh shoot.
Get the butt!
Oh, I'm out of ammo.
I'm out of ammo.
Raiden, be careful!
Raiden, you got... You guys are probably... I can't even look at the left side or the right side of the screen.
Here, I'll move you guys over so you can watch him.
I'll move you guys over here.
So you guys can see everything that's going on with Raiden.
Oh, and me too.
I'll be on this side for the...
Sorry for taking so long with it.
I don't know if you guys were asking me to do it or not.
It's this one, right?
I think so.
M82A2?
Let me double check.
Yes.
Wow, those are expensive.
Let's do like...
Ah, it's ok.
We've made so much... We're almost back to where we were before.
Left your cool war stuff right here.
Hot yaoi moment.
This part is an autoscroller, so we have time to read donations.
Oh shoot, I forgot to...
There we go.
What is the weak point?
Oh my god.
The ass!
The ass is the weak point!
Oh shoot.
Who's also attack...
Oh my gosh, awkward.
No!
Thank you.
Oh my gosh, I keep running right into these bozos though.
I'm so dumb.
Hello?
Oh, I'm out of bullets?
Wait, but I just bought bullets!
Guys, did I buy the wrong bullets?
I literally just bought...
Did I buy the wrong bullets?
I used that many already?
No way!
Flip.
Should we use the railgun?
We can try it.
Let's try the railgun.
Oh, I already have it equipped.
Railgun!
Oh, wrong thing.
Not the iPod.
Nope, nope, nope.
I still want my ration equipped.
Come on!
Shoot!
I can't!
You guys, this was a terrible idea!
Oh fuck!
Oh my gosh.
At least they're on sale!
I'm trying!
I can't determine what their weak spot is.
I think I'm bad at the game.
The head?
Is it?
Sure, we'll use the Patriot in the dire moment.
Which is this.
What was that?
Oh my gosh!
Okay,
okay.
Oh my god!
I couldn't avoid that one!
That was one shot, baby!
That's right!
Go down!
Down, girl!
Down!
I need to run in here when they start...
coming after me.
Anymore?
Rion, are you okay up there?
Rion, are you good?
I think we're clean!
Alright!
Oh shoot!
We're not clean.
Where is he?
Oh my gosh.
Ouch!
Oh my god.
I didn't mean to...
Thank you.
I think I'm dying a little.
Those my body parts?
Oh my god.
Stop stretching!
Woo!
Stop shooting me!
There's more over there.
Oh my god.
You son of a gun.
Thank
you.
Where?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Where are they?
I see them.
Have you guys seen that cow?
I think it's a cow.
He goes...
No!
I won't let you.
Oh my god.
I'm out of bullets.
Shit.
Okay.
Time to buy more.
They are like, you found your moon.
He goes...
I'm trying!
No!
One shot.
What?
Raiden, are you okay?
Kill him already, please.
Thank you.
Wow.
Ask and you shall receive.
Look at his little smile.
What a beautiful thing to see this.
This guy.
Die!
Oh my gosh.
Thank you for the raid.
I hope you had fun with Doom.
Sorry if you guys are coming in here.
This is a lot of spoilers.
It's okay if you leave.
If you plan on playing Metal Gear, don't watch!
Thank you for the gifted, you guys.
Thank you, Spank.
Thank you, Robin.
Thank you, Zipley.
Okay, welcome to Mambushu.
This is like huge, huge spoilers, you guys.
Close your eyes.
Go away.
I mean, hi, KFB.
Thanks.
Thanks, Chara, for the raid.
Superliminal things are the thing of the day.
Oh,
Raiden got a little bit of his... on your face.
Why?
I don't want your crocodile tears.
I love, like, a little bit of the opening, like, the title screen music of MGS1.
She was going to.
Until he told her that.
She even has it out and everything.
I'm sorry.
I'm going to eat crackers while I watch.
Oh, my God.
That's the man that killed Otacon's sister.
And she still acts like that.
Shut up!
It's ended.
Snake.
Liquids down below us.
He's stolen the Patriot system, slipped out of their sight and taken their Ark.
Ark?
A warship.
Unfettered by land, law, country or network.
The only place where they are truly released from the shackles of the Patriots.
The place where they can be free.
Outer Haven.
Liquid plans to launch the nuke from that ship.
Snake.
You have been given life so that you may fulfill your purpose.
When all of this is over, you'll have no choice but to accept death.
Shut up!
You are such a miserable human being!
So that we can atone for our sins.
Your life was created for that very purpose.
I hate her so much.
We all must atone for our sins.
She puts these stupid thoughts into Snake's head.
We must not pass them on to the next generation.
We must not leave them for the future.
That is your true fate.
One that even you cannot defy.
Oh yeah!
Woo!
We are the same.
We're living corpses.
Our bodies kept barely alive by nanomachines.
I'm you.
Cancer.
Yeah, you are.
You are a cancer in my afterlife, Naomi Hunter.
Please.
But there's nothing more they can do.
With the nanomachines gone...
Time will unfreeze and begin to flow again.
What are you saying?
Oh my god.
Goodbye.
Hell.
Don't!
And she also, she really did not have to do this.
She did not have to do this.
And she does it in front of him!
So he can just watch her die!
You're so fucked up, Naomi Hunter.
Nobody ever have... Look at them, just looking down on you.
Nobody has sympathy for you!
Give the best to Sunny.
Naomi, don't do it.
She's gotta be the main character.
She's gotta have the most dramatics.
She's gotta be the one on everybody's mind.
It's even funnier the second time.
Not for Otacon though.
Why?
That's a great question, Otacon!
That is a really good question.
Why?
Maximum trauma achieved.
You'll remember me.
You're so messed up.
Please, you are so messed up, Naomi Hunter.
Look, and she takes the camera down with her.
So that he'll just watch her die.
We
gotta get out of here.
A little part 3.
Yeah,
you're right.
You're right, Gaspar.
Otacon, you're too good for her.
You're too good for her.
You saw, you saw the way she cradled Vamp in her arms.
She didn't have to do that either.
Please, please, Otacon!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Put your glasses on.
Snake is right here.
I'm done crying.
I don't have any more tears to shed.
We have to get out of here.
Any ideas?
Time's running short, so I'll explain as we go.
Pay close attention.
But listen...
Ok, no time to cry, guys.
We gotta power Rex!
Bye, Naomi.
Rest in hell.
I wish we'd step on you, just like how your fucking brother died!
Die, Naomi!
Suffer!
Suffer all by yourself!
Die!
Gotta have the last word.
Our will.
Fuck off!
Always gotta have the last word, Naomi Hunter.
Goddamn, I hate you!
Mint is so irrationally mad!
No, no, this is 100% warranted.
This is 100% warranted for her.
She's the worst character.
She's so bad!
Perfectly rational.
Yeah!
Rationally mad.
Yeah, she's like a cockroach!
And we hate those!
Yeah!
She died as she lived, stabbing people with random needles.
I love while we're back on Shadow Moses, Otacon mirrors, snakes, I have no more tears to shed.
It's a good moment.
If not for Naomi's involvement.
I know, it really is!
Ding dong!
The witch is dead!
That's honestly the best part of this act, too.
Everything is good in this act.
We see...
We get to go back to Shadow Moses!
We get to see Naomi die!
And now we get to go pilot Rex!
Oh,
oh, gosh.
How do I shoot?
How do I shoot this thing?
Oh, L1, R1 to fire.
What's this?
Which one should we do?
The laser might take too long.
Oh my god!
I am pressing, right?
Yeah, R1.
My ears!
Oh my god, my ears!
Oh my god!
We're taking the whole place down with us!
How did I miss?
Which way?
This way.
I'm going!
Am I gonna die here?
I hope not.
Oh, that would be fine.
I get to just pilot Rex again!
Shoot all of them!
Not just one of them!
I think I'm not using this thing to its full ability.
Oh my god!
What just happened?
Our health!
Our health, baby!
Oh god!
I can't hear a damn thing!
Oh my god!
Gatlin is better for this one?
OK.
Oh, it's unlimited ammo!
I wish I had known that.
Oh my god, our health is so little.
We're gonna die!
We're not gonna make it!
I think that was the end, was it not?
Were we right there?
OK, we got... I know.
I'm going!
We're stomping them!
We're going!
Yep, don't worry about it.
Don't worry about it Otacon!
I got it!
Oh my god!
I've got to handle the Otacon!
Don't worry about it!
Oh my gosh, Raiden.
Don't... Raiden should be
more.
So many more.
Take him down!
I can't see anything!
That's just chaos, it really is.
OK.
We were so close before.
It's time.
One last fight before the end of the act.
And what truly makes this one of the best acts in the game... or the best acts in the game...
This might be the best moment in the game, in this act.
Get in the robot Mito moment.
Gosh.
Raiden, did you make it out?
OK, he's fine.
Raiden!
He's fine.
Outer Haven!
Raiden!
Rules of nature.
No.
This is a...
Oh
gosh.
OK.
Otacon, how do I... Actually, how do I need to...
How do I...
Over here.
You first!
Oh my god.
What should we put on you guys?
What song do you want to listen to?
Some of the Enders?
K-Pop?
What?
Love to turn to Hell Havoc.
The game isn't out yet.
Idol music.
Get up, Rex!
This is basically Love to Turrets.
Where is he?
Oh, he's over here.
Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah.
OK.
Oh my god.
Ouch!
Thank you.
Thanks.
I couldn't look for signs.
He was literally... Oh my god.
Wow!
Oh, now you tell me!
Oh god.
Seriously, Otacon?
Should I try maybe another one?
I want to try the laser cannon.
Wait, it has to power up though, right?
Oh shit.
Ouch.
Where is he?
OK, I think... I should have... I should have waited for it, but it's OK.
Oh shit, I should have dodged.
No!
Ouch!
He gets one, I get one.
At
the peak of the song!
That was so epic!
It was so good!
Oh my god!
Oh my ears, holy cow.
That was so awesome!
No!
Ray was designed to be a Metal Gear killer, and it couldn't take down Rex.
Skill issue for sure.
Oh my god.
Oh my gosh.
My favorite part.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Nobody say it!
Wait, wait, wait!
Don't say it!
Oh my god.
Fox
Think again!
Dead Nash!
Oh, a stick!
Think again!
Oh my god, wait.
Here it is!
Yes!
The best scene ever in a video game!
Melt Snakemore!
I love this game!
Keep going, Snake!
I will destroy JD!
Then, everything ends, and everything begins!
But as for you, brother...
You'll stay here to mark this island's watery grave!
No!
We won the fight!
Die, Snake!
My master has been buried under rubble this entire time.
We didn't even try to help him!
Raiden!
Oh my god.
Oh, it's so pitiful.
Raiden is a better mom for Sunny than Naomi was.
Oh, Snake.
Oh god!
Snake, move!
Please, Snake!
Oh no.
Yeah, it was in front of Federal Hall.
There were all these tourists around here.
They were asking me which building it was that King Kong was climbing in the movie.
I said it was probably the Chrysler Building.
And then you showed up and started mouthing off.
You were like, no, it's the Empire State.
I said the Chrysler Building was in Godzilla.
We started arguing, and I forgot all about the tourists.
The next thing we knew, the tourists had gone away.
And a week later, I found you again by coincidence out in the base corridor.
An amazing coincidence.
Yeah, coincidence.
That night, we went up to the top of the Empire State Building.
It was so beautiful.
I didn't care anymore who was right.
And that was our first date.
We watched King Kong in your apartment a bunch of times that night.
Oh yeah!
That's what the kids called it back then.
King Kong all night.
Oh my gosh, how many people thought that Raiden died there?
I mean, obviously we know that he did it because of Revengeance, but...
So it's not a spoiler or anything.
I thought he did, yeah.
I kinda wish I had played the game when it came out.
But I'm also really glad that I got to play it when I did.
Raiden who wasn't strong enough to lift Ruffalo.
Don't think about it.
Raiden!
Oh, his sword!
Don't think about it.
Oh, a snake!
115 kills, baby!
Wow, we spent 2 million GP and we still got 100,000 more than we did...
Almost 100,000 more than we did last week, so...
Act 4.
Act 4 I feel is when it starts to really feel...
Actually, no.
Act 3 is definitely when it starts to feel super duper...
Hopeless, I'd say.
Instinct Night!
Thank you for the 20 gift!
Act 3 is when it starts to feel really hopeless and then...
Act 4 is nostalgia trip until the end and you're just like...
Oh gosh, it's not good.
It's not good!
And then...
Act 5.
Next week.
The conclusion of...
Metal Gear Solid 4.
The conclusion of Solid Snake's timeline.
Darky, thanks for the 5 gifted!
I'm wondering if we should save the briefing for next week.
Darkray, thanks for the 10 gifted!
Should we save the briefing or should we do it now?
I think it might be good to...
You guys, next week, bring your popcorn, okay?
Bring your popcorn next week because we have some super duper long...
Cutscenes to go through!
Thank you for the 15 gifted!
Thank you so much!
Now we got a 2 hour cutscene.
We still have fights to do still, obviously, but...
My favorite Naomi quote, I'm gonna choose life too!
Honestly, she just becomes such a villain in this game.
In Metal Gear Solid, obviously, she's just stupidly annoying.
You're just like, girl, how long do I have left to live?
But she's just so hopeful.
And in this game, she puts such negative thoughts into Snake's brain that it really pisses me off!
StarCreator, thanks for the 10 gifted!
She's just so mean in this game!
She's so mean!
You hate Naomi more than Rose?
Oh my gosh, I love Rose, sorry.
I love the soap opera that is Metal Gear Solid 2, so you can never make me hate Rose.
Maybe that's a... what's the word?
A... what's the word?
What's the word when it's...
Problematic?
Not problematic.
Controversial!
Yeah, a controversial take.
Hi, thanks for the 10 gifted!
And you know what, I'll take it.
I'll take it as a controversial take, because I know a lot of people are like, I can't stand Rose.
She's so annoying in MGS2.
But she's... oh my gosh, it's too funny, I can't hate it.
The two of them bickering the entire time.
It's so funny, I love it.
I love it.
I can't get enough of it.
I want more of it.
I want her to just be like, Jack, why don't you call me?
And he's just like, Rose, I'm in the middle of battle.
She's like, also don't call me Jack, my name is Raiden.
Oh my gosh, Jack, you had no furniture in your room.
That's so good, I'm dead, but I live for that.
It's so funny.
Popcorn funds, I pretty much never buy popcorn, but I definitely will for the next session.
One good thing about Naomi, after meeting her Raiden never thought of Rose as an egotistical woman again.
Piloting Rex's catharsis for the Rex boss fight.
Oh gosh, it's too good.
It's so funny.
Popcorn!
MGS4 Watchalong, yeah!
But Naomi just feels entirely malicious this entire game.
I don't care what her intentions are.
She comes off as so horrible and malicious the entire time.
And I'm just... I don't even think that the payoff...
Not to spoil anything, but it's not worth it to me.
Because she just comes off again, again in the very last part.
She self inserts herself as the main character.
She's not a Mary Sue, but she wants to be the all powerful main character.
She's trying to steal the limelight, she's trying to get the last word.
She's just so insufferable.
And she's so mean.
She's so mean to everybody.
Poor, poor Otacon.
Notorious, thanks for the five gifted!
Thanks for the stream and showing off your alternate colors.
Act 4 is peak, I love me some mecha fights.
Yeah!
Yeah, and I don't know if you guys saw, but like...
When I do this, I become...
Like, you see?
I become RGB.
I can be any color!
I can be... I can be any...
Let's see...
Oh, I can't show you right now, because my monitor is kind of messed up.
I can cycle... I can be... I can choose anything that I want!
Yeah, orange!
I can be orange!
I can be Wawa!
Thanks for the stream, Boss Minku!
And we are eating popcorn for the next stream of Metal Gear.
What flavor should I make?
Homemade?
Homemade!
What's your favorite?
I like kettle corn.
But maybe cheese?
Oh my gosh!
I might get one of those...
I might get one of those... Thanks!
Number one!
Thank you!
I might get one of those tins that has like the caramel and the regular and the cheesy popcorn in it.
Sync up snacks?
Oh my gosh, that's so exciting!
But I really like kettle corn.
Cookies and cream!
Just get your favorite.
Get your favorite snack.
Man... I love this game.
I love this game, despite everything.
I love this game.
I'm sorry guys that I couldn't get all the...
Oh wait!
Before we... Wait...
We might have... I wanted to do the spirit photography.
Naomi, like myself, did nothing... Shut up, Huey!
Preach Dr. Emmerich!
We don't need two Hueys in the chat!
We don't need two Huey apologists in the chat!
Who's Huey?
Well, maybe you'll find out if you watch Peace Walker.
And then you'll see why everybody hates him and...
Well, first we gotta get through Peace Walker and then 5.
Oh 5!
Oh gosh.
I wanna get back to the main menu.
I'm gonna press the start real quick.
And see what happens.
Save the game, yes.
Because I do need to save, obviously.
Thanks for act 4, looking forward to next week.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
One second.
I might be able to skip it through.
Oh, it won't even... If I press start, nothing happens.
No way.
Hold on.
Yeah, I wanna view from the main menu!
Let me view from the main menu!
I don't necessarily wanna skip because I don't want you guys to see the beginning of the act, but...
Maybe I...
I know.
Here, hold on.
I'm gonna exit the game.
Right it.
Turn off the game console.
Right now.
Yeah, we're gonna go to the home button.
And we're gonna close the game.
Quit game.
I gotta turn my date back to...
To...
The correct day because...
Next week, I will be finishing it on Sunday.
I have something to do next Saturday.
So, I won't have time...
To do it.
So, Sunday will be...
Why does the date matter?
Because there's a shop in the game.
And the shop does discounts on Sundays and Wednesday.
And I changed the date to be Sunday.
I changed the date to be Sunday so...
So that we could get a little bit of extra discount on today.
When I bought stuff.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh yeah, and there's even more discount on Act 5.
Exactly.
So we'll get so... Wait, does it stack?
The Sunday discount plus the Act 5 discount.
The discount is permanent on Act 5.
But it's a big... Isn't it like 50% off?
Wait, I'm seeing no and then I'm seeing it stacks.
I feel like I trust you, Chikado.
Chikado, Chikado, Chikado.
Howdy man, cute hair.
By the way, you got some cookies.
Thank you!
Hooray!
It's Sunday in Japan.
True!
Alright, let's see all my failures.
Oh, and also some sexy pictures.
This one...
Okay guys, look, look, look.
Look, look, look, look.
Exercise all ghosts from the photo.
This is Minto from Beyond Beyond the Grave.
Thank you for watching today's stream.
I will show you one last thing before you go.
Ta-da!
Oh, sorry.
Wait,
I can't get rid of my headband.
Actually, I can.
There we go!
Watcher!
OtsuMinto!
See you for Act 5 next week!
Thank you!